>> FE OF
TEXAOVER THE STATECONTRSION
PLAN.
WE'LL HEROF.
CHIEF TOMAER DCR
PRESENTIFR 2CKCATONIGHT.ORITY LR
NT. STAKE INY VIEWR X WS T'S COT
VA WITWH
CAKS. EMENT OFFICIAL HERE AT THE
>> ON THOT OF THE TOL, HOWEVER,E
OF  W
GAVE FOX EXCLUSIVE A SECURITY F.
KNGLEWERS ABOUT THO HAVE
ELECTION, LIES T T
VERY SAME T  C
NOW, TAPITOLICF
SAYSHANNELENTLY VIO CALMER MING
INSURRTIONHO
EIH BACK, VIDEO OF RIOTECOCHAN
THIS WAS PRESENTED WITHOUT THE
FULLER CONTEXT AS IFS VIDEO
OFOW CHANCELY  GINAPOL BUI
W. COURT DOCUMENTSOF COURSE,
THEYAID RI
REPEAT TO GET THMA
LEAVE THE CAPITOL AN
FELONY CHARGES RELATED TO HITIN.
NO F CLAIMED THE SMALL PROVED TH
COMMITTEE HA BICAN PEOPLE  H
HAPPENING THAT DAY AND VERUTVIWN
NE
INSIDEINE
INSURRECTION.
AGAIN, T REPUBLICANS.
>> THI
I MEANHAVE NOTEE
I PLOYED T I07 2008.
IS WHAT IS HAPPENI D SAKLE'S HOH
VIOLENEV WINS. >> S SOF
E OW TRUE OU
JANUARY 6t WCC
MORE THA,0RSCAPITOL SECURITY FO
SPEAKER CARTHY.
GAS AB
R S NEWS OR
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
THEM, WE HAVE
ACO E  FOOTA A
FFICE SAYSARE ON IT.
ANOTHER FACT, THIS MOVS ME TIMEN
SUED BY DOMINION VG SYSTEMS
SO F HOSTS LIEABOUT E OX S20CTI.
HE AIRE
KNOW
TEXTED
EACHER V LIARS
DERANGED NON-SENSE THEY
COVERED AND IN SOM
PLATRMIS ANUT.
NO ONE WILITH HER.
DITTNI BUT
ELEVATING THESLSE CONSPIRACY
RUPERT MURDOCH WHEKE DEPOSITIOIR
SERIOUSLTH OF
LIDED E ELEC F
OH, YES ANR OATH,
D HAVE LIKED
STNG IT IN EL, THAT McCARTHY HAD
ACCESS TO THE
FOOTAGE., FOX USED
THE FOOTAGE GIVEN TO THEM BY
DESCRIPTION OF THE EVENTS OF
JANUARY 6th WHERE THY ED AND VYS
WHERE THE SE INS A
LIE.RECOLLECTION THEY
S- S A
LIE.
FOUR TRUMP SUPPORTERS DIED THATS
E JANUARh INCLFROM T UNRY D AFTH
JANUARY 6tS GOSAID. O ALTERNATE,
CONTRADICTS PEOPLEREDA
CONTRADICTS TO
OFFICERS.
NT MEMBERSRYSS
DOTOSPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
A WALL AND TALKED
ABOUT MURDERTH
PRESIDEN
RI
THE FLOOR OF T D LAW ENFORCEMEN
>> WAS ELECTROCUTE
I MEAN, I SAIENDS LEEDING.E THRU
ALL OVER THEIR FACWAPING IN PE'
>> THIS MORNING I REACHED OUTO
SPEAKE'SASKED FOUR SIMPLE QUS.
SPEAKER OF E HOUSE ' CONCLUSIO
DEADLY INSUR LIE
ER OF THE HOUSE
OF THE HOEMRSE LENT?
JANUARY 6th SELECT HOUSE E LIEDN
THSERI FOOTA
ANAKER OF THE
HOUSE AGREE THAT QUOTE THE 2020?
SO FAR, SPEAKER McCARTHYSPONDED.
ONDER HOMU FACTS
DOE OF THE CONTINUEDARGUMENT THS
AMERICAN
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS
TIFOX' AIRING OF
WELL, LET'S TAKE AT DO YOUHITU U
FOOTAGE FROM SPEAKERcC
AND WE ALWAY PLAY
JANUARY
SAID PEACEFUL
CHAOS IN HIEW ANSAIDN-INSUTI
'S DEATH WAS NOTth.
I WAS DOWNHEI  T.
PEOPLE TT  INGS BUT YOU
BARRICADES BREACHED. POLICFIASS
CAPITOL HILLNUYOTO REPUBLICANS G
THEIR REACTION TO FOG OFOOTAGEN.
WHRELLYOU?
>> THEY ARNG ICLR EYY E
WHASHI OEY LIVED
HAPPENED.
THEY SAW WHAHE IS,
VICE WAS.EADLY THE
MANY O ALL HAD T
AND WLY VIOLENCR THAT DAY
AT THE HANDSF
MODERATE REPUBLICANST BROKE
OP
THE UNITED STATES CAPITOL OWS AG
OF LI IS
A
WHINTO T CHAMBER
THEIR BALCON PUT
THAT IN THE SAME CATEGORAS AKNO
IS --IT WASATE
ERRE A THETIHINK WERED
CHARLESTON THE SECURITE ERON>> T
D Y ATON
IT W
McCARTT  AND DANGEROUS AND HE  F
TUCKERESTON.
NO McCARTHY F.D HIM IN THE CAP
HE  HSW
TODAY ABOUT ALL THIS SO WE'LL EE